- [Gary] Guys, say
hello to my friend Jess.
(audience cheers and applause)
So, thanks guys for hanging.
So I emailed Jess the other day.
I was like, "Hey, if you
come through to New York,
"I'd love to do a
fireside chat with the company."
I want to do more of
these with you guys and
I couldn't of
thought of a better guest.
Obviously, we got to know
each other quite a bit filming
Planet of the Apps but I've
always known from afar when we
ran into each other a couple
non-profit events through the
years of how impressive of a
operator and an entrepreneur and
a thinker about marketing,
media and business
Jess has been for
quite a long time.
Obviously, she had real fame
before that world and so
I don't think a lot of
people, you know,
that are paying
attention realize it.
And then I got to really see it
on display from a business chops
standpoint on the show.
Obviously, the show is very
real and like we were critiquing
businesses and asking questions.
- Yeah.
- I really enjoyed it and
I'm just extremely fond of her
so one more time please clap it
up for somebody I respect.
(audience
applauds enthusiastically)
So I think I'm gonna
ask a couple questions
and then I think
we'll open it up to
some questions and then
we'll all go on our merry ways.
So, first and foremost Jess,
when did you start thinking
about or realize that
you had business interests?
- Hmmm.
I think I always
approached my career,
even when I was 12
when I started acting,
I was like what's the long game?
How do I stay relevant and how
do I become a real player and
how am I going to be meaningful?
And so I was always
pretty strategic in the way that
I approached my career
and I thought of
myself as a brand
before it was a thing to
think of yourself as a brand.
I was always really cognizant
that anything I associated
myself with was going to be
reflective of how
people thought of me.
- Yep.
- And I protected that
for a long time
and when I decided to
launch my own brand
I really feel like
all of that thought
really got channeled in
in the best way.
I didn't know what the outcome
would be but I was certainly
very aware of being protective
of my image from day one.
- So on that note, I'm
actually remembering this from a
conversation now,
let's dig a little bit deeper.
Was there ever a role that you
really jockeyed for or strategic
for or was there anything that
CAA and those characters were
pushing you hard to do that you
passed on based on this thesis?
- Yeah.
- Tell us.
- Both.
(audience laughter)
- Everything.
- So I never got to really show
my chops as a
really dramatic actress
when I was young because
I wouldn't show my boobs.
(Gary and audience laugh)
All the good
roles were sexy time
and I was like,
I for whatever reason
I felt like when I was
young it would just be exploited
in a way and out of my control
in a way that I felt wouldn't
be great for my brand before
I really
articulated it that way.
And I also grew up
Catholic and Christian,
I couldn't ever deal with my
dad seeing me do that stuff.
- Dad.
- My dad's here.
- That's true.
(audience laughter)
- And so I grew up with the
guilt and the things and the
weirdness and so
that played into it.
But yeah,
I definitely took more
or passed up on a lot of
opportunities that would've
positioned me as an actress in
Hollywood in a different way.
Maybe in a more serious way.
But on the flip side,
I went the route of
wanting to be global.
Wanting to--
- So is that
like superhero time?
Is that that?
- Yeah, I looked at the
marketplace and I was like
what are the
things that go global?
And it was
superhero franchises, action,
it was pre-horror and
it was pre-rom com being global.
And so rom com was to make
you America's Sweetheart but it
really didn't extend beyond that
but you can get a decent payday
and you can be the
face of a beauty brand.
Fine.
Or you can transcend
that, the girl stuff,
and you can go into boy land
and you can do action hero
and I wanted to
be an action hero.
- 'Cause you wanted to collect
yourself as an action figure?
- Well, yeah.
(audience laughter)
- Of course.
- I have a few.
(audience laughter)
So yeah, I've been in many
action figures over the years.
When I started with a TV show
I did with James Cameron called
"Dark Angel" I was
actually offered--
- Oh, we remember.
(audience laughter)
- I was 17 and I was like if I
don't get real role by the time
I'm 18 that's going to really
make me feel comfortable with
choosing this as a path as a
career than I'm going to go to
school and get a
degree and have a real job.
- So really at that point in
your career you were like okay--
- So between 16 and 18 I gave
myself two years to really kind
of figure out if this was
supposed to be my path in life
and I was offered a role in
"The Fast and The Furious" and
I was also offered
the starring role of
James Cameron's first TV show
his first project
after he did Titanic.
I took the James Cameron one.
And then from there I
was like,
"Alright, I guess these are the
stars aligning telling me that
"I should maybe
do this for a living."
So yeah, from there I just
thought strategically about how
to maintain that
global awareness
and I didn't want to
be the girl to the guy
that put asses in seats,
I wanted to be the
girl who put asses in seats.
And the way to do that was with
action franchises at the time.
- Very cool. So, how do
you think about it now?
Are you out?
You gonna act again?
Where are you in--
- Well, it's tough.
I really haven't focused on
this business for nine years.
- Has it been that, really?
- It's been a long time.
- When you say that,
what does that mean?
It's been nine years since what?
- Since I really
cared about it--
- Like that way. (laughs)
Okay.
- Well, no, like--
- Since you put, yeah
- my focus, I sort of--
- Well, you've
done stuff, right?
- Yeah, but I got pregnant
and I had a kid at 27,
I got pregnant at
26 and had her at 27.
And I'd been working
for so long, at that point,
I'd been working since I was 12,
and hardcore
really since I was 17 so,
it was a solid 10 years of
not having a personal life.
- Yep.
- And not really having
any life outside of working
90 hour weeks often.
So, I didn't sleep much,
and I worked a lot,
and it was a blessing because
it was a dream come true.
But then, when I actually sat in
one place for the first time,
and I had a person
growing in my stomach,
and I was like oh my
goodness, she's gonna rely on me
to stay alive.
(audience laughs)
- That is true.
- How am I gonna do that?
So, then my
perspective just shifted
on what it means to
have the luck to be alive
and to have your
health and to want to
I don't know, operate with a
different sense of purpose.
- Nate, right over
there in the pink shirt,
Nathan, excuse me, he
freaked out when he found out
that the odds of
being a human are
four hundred trillion to one.
That happened to him in
L.A. when we were filming.
So, he feels that same feeling.
(audience laughter)
- Congratulations, Nate.
- So, talk about the
early days of the business.
It's such a big business now,
all of you should
I don't know if
you take visitors,
but you should
all visit the offices--
- Yeah, we do!
- It's just growing
up so in such a big way.
Obviously, we've
worked with Unilever
and Johnson & Johnson, and it
gets brought up all the time.
And it's so crazy because--
- We're like the
little engine that could.
- That's fine, but you're--
- You work with like--
- Yes, but, but--
- the giants.
- They're all scared, right,
and they're all aware,
and they're all impressed,
and I think it gets compounded.
It's just so impressive to watch
you build something so real
and so big and compete
at the at a global scale...
And what's interesting
is that you're going
into a different chapter, right?
You guys were this
digital-native brand,
and now it's just
getting bigger and bigger.
- For our main channel, yeah.
- Yeah, and it's happening here.
They know we're not
25 people anymore, right?
So, you change.
But, you don't change in spirit,
you just look
differently at 12 and 17
and 26 and what have you.
How are you thinking
about the business?
What's exciting?
What's interesting?
Give us a quick, little update.
- Well, I think
what's interesting about
life in general,
it's something that,
I guess I only really came to
when I got older, was
I decided, at some point,
that as right as
I ever thought I was
when I was 18 telling my parents
all the thoughts in the world
about how things should be, Dad.
And I had all the opinions
and said all the things.
I never wanted to be the same
person 10 years from then.
And, as a company,
five years ago,
we were a very
different company.
And we've grown up.
And I hope five years from now,
we will be even more grown up.
Now, having wisdom
doesn't mean that you should
not have life and spirit.
It doesn't mean that
you shouldn't be open
and still try and learn
and change and evolve.
It just means that you
have hopefully the wisdom
to not make the same mistake
more than two or three times.
(audience laughter)
Because that just really blows,
making the same
mistakes over and over again.
We're an Omnichannel brand
as far as distribution goes.
Our model has changed a bit.
We are in more
verticals, more expansive
as far as--
- You're hardcore in the
beauty thing, now, right?
- Yeah, we're in beauty.
We're launching cleaning
at the end of the year.
We started primarily
in baby and personal care
and basic cleaning,
but we're really going
deep in verticals
where we know we can win
and where people
have asked us to play in.
We've really kind of evolved
into a health
and wellness company.
At the end of the day,
a company that
puts human health first,
no matter what
category we go into.
It really doesn't matter,
and education is as important
as the products that we make,
and just, you know,
being able to empower people
with the knowledge
to make better choices,
to me, is the ultimate mission.
- So talk to me about,
so this company
started from social, right?
Talk to me about your personal
social media behaviors.
How do you roll?
Do you create like fake
accounts and troll people?
You're a character,
so I know something
weird could come out here.
- You know, I tried to do that.
I really tried to do it
'cause I feel like
I have an alter ego.
(audience laughter)
And I tried to
have like, you know,
my social media alter ego that's
like a little bit naughty.
- Really?
(audience laughter)
- But I couldn't do it.
It was like too
much work, and--
- So do have a,
do you use anything?
- No, I use all the things.
But I started on Twitter.
That was my first.
- Yep.
- That was my first account.
And then I went to
Facebook, and then Instagram,
and then--
- Do you Snap?
- Snapchat, yeah.
And Pinterest around
the time of Instagram.
I have to say like whenever
I'm going through a transition
in my life, or something
new is happening like
I have a new office
or got a new house
or making over a room,
like I pin my life away.
- Really?
- Yeah, it's funny how
it's not like as consistent
as like a Snapchat
or an Instagram,
but it's much
more like maniacal.
- Utility when
you actually need it.
- But it's like intense.
- Like you're into it.
- It's like way too much time.
- You like pin the
fuck out of Pinterest.
- I pin the fuck out of my life
'til two in the
morning every night.
- (laughs) I love it.
- I don't even know what's
wrong with my brain right now.
But, yeah, so I'm like...
- And where are you most
active day to day right now?
- I'm on Instagram
and Snapchat,
and it's--
- And is your public
profile that has the millions
and millions of people following
the one that you actually use?
- Yeah.
- So how do you get
through all the noise,
like creeper dudes like Trouty?
(audience laughter)
- If Trouty posts an
inappropriate picture,
- Yes?
- then I block him.
- Got it.
(audience laughter)
He's clearly been blocked.
- He's like so red.
- So red, so red!
This is the greatest moment
in this
company's history, period!
(audience laughter and applause)
Got it, so you just
kinda just navigate through it.
- Yeah, I should actually
be a little bit more
strategic with social media,
but for some reason I'm not.
And I don't like
know to post at, you know,
the better time
of the day to post--
- Right.
- is at this time.
And you should post
this type of content versus
that type of like, I don't--
- Yeah.
You're just rolling with it.
- I don't follow the rules.
- I get it, I get it.
- I just like,
- You're doing your thing.
- if I'm making lunch
up and I'm so inspired--
- Yep.
- You know I'm gonna do
a little video
- Something.
- of my nachos.
(Gary laughs)
And that's my life.
Or I'm like into my new kicks,--
- Right.
- you're gonna
see a photo of them.
- I love it, it's good.
So why don't you
tell everybody here
a little bit about
Planet of the Apps.
How did that go?
You know, was that fun?
- How do you think it went?
- I thought I was great.
(audience laughter)
- I don't know if you
guys know this about him,
but all he did was scream.
(audience laughter)
The entire time.
They actually had
to bring our mics,
like our voices up to
match your scream roll.
- Yeah.
- So that we could
be at the same level.
- It's really cool.
We filmed in three
sets, like you pitch,
then we mentor,
which I did in L.A.
Big ups L.A.
And then we pitch to the VC,
but they do an
episode where they follow
all the way through.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So the first episode of--
- So you can see the beginning,
the middle, and the end
of the journey of
these entrepreneurs, right?
- Yes, and I
think it's really cool
because the first
episode is really featuring
on our companies.
- Yeah, it's us.
- So I'm excited.
- Really we
shouldn't tell people that.
- Right, we're in trouble now.
So, but seriously,
was it interest,
like how'd it go for you?
- It was a little work.
- It was.
- It was like stressful,
because, I don't know, I mean,
when you're thinking of
running your own company,
you, like, you don't
stop thinking about it,
and you know how
important it is to you.
And it is--
- It's your life.
- It's your life,
and to come, you know,
it doesn't matter
what gets in the way,
you're gonna figure out
how to like push through
and make things happen.
And when things
don't happen the way
that you want them to
happen, you're devastated.
- Yeah, that was not the,
- And that's like--
- Like when we didn't
pick them, that was bad.
- (sighing) It's so
hard, it's horrible.
- But, but the lessons-
- But some of them deserved it
- because their company sucked.
(audience laughter)
- That's true, but,
the problem is in their minds,
they don't know that they suck.
- Well yeah, we've
all seen American Idol,
and the person's like,
"I'm the greatest
singer of all time,"
and then they rip
our ears off our bodies.
- You know it hurts
them as much as it hurts--
- Yeah no, for sure.
- There's like
a very human thing there,
and so you
don't want to devastate
them to the point of them
not wanting to continue,
but at the same time,
- Well, Will--
- if something like this
devastates them that much,
then they are completely shot.
- Then they have no shot.
That's exactly right.
- Exactly.
- And Will wouldn't
allow them to be devastated,
because every time
they would make it through,
he ran down, hugged them,
he gave them his cell number
and decide to be
best friends with them.
(audience laughter)
So let's flip it.
Are you-
- (mumbles).
- If he asks, too much fun.
(audience laughter)
What about your
media consumption?
What shows are you watching,
podcasts you're listening to-
- I like your shoes.
- You like them?
- Yeah.
- So are you
consuming any shows?
(audience laughter)
- Wait, what are your socks?
- Oh, Star Wars.
- Is it Star Wars?
- Yeah.
- Oh, I like Star Wars.
- Mhmmm, yeah.
- Excellent. Yep.
- I'm sorry.
What shows am I watching?
- Yes.
- Um...
Big Little Lies.
(audience cheering)
- Hands in the air.
(audience cherring)
Let's go.
- It's like a telenovela
with a lot of white people.
- Yep.
(audience laughter)
That's exactly right.
- It has all the drama,
- Yep.
- It's like really good.
- Is it good?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- It's really good.
- What else?
- Um...hmm...
So I haven't finished the OA,
don't ruin it for me.
- [Kim] We don't have to.
- It's,
(audience laughter)
It likes warms my brain,
- Kim keeps it real.
- It's just like
it gives me anxiety,
and it's like
the late-night watch
of the thing
that's gonna (inaudible).
Hi Pierre.
My friend Pierre.
- Hey Pierre.
- His family's made macaroons,
you know macaroons?
The french little...
(background noise
drowns out other sounds)
He gets mad at how, mac-a-woon,
you have to say it like that.
- Sheesh.
- Oh, anyway, so he's there.
- Let's clap it up for him.
(audience applause)
[Jessica] You know a lot of way?
- [Gary] What's that?
- [Jessica] A lot of ways.
- Mhmmm, gotcha.
- And what do you watch?
I don't--
- Nothing.
(audience laughter)
- You... watch yourself?
- This is true.
Yes.
(audience laughter)
That's exactly right.
You nailed it.
You pretty much nailed it.
I'm really not
watching anything,
but that's because
I... and he's working,
- Oh, do you see the...
- Yep.
- (mumbles) Bauer?
Yes, it's an
important documentary.
He's on the 13TH.
- He's what?
- [Pierre] He's (mumbles).
- You saw the 13th, right?
(audience applause)
- [Pierre] Oh.
- You saw that
documentary, right?
- Nope.
- Oh, Jesus.
- But I do love documentaries,
and if I consume
anything, it's normally that,
but I haven't seen it.
- You need to see it.
- Okay.
- It's important.
- Okay, I'm in.
- It actually really matters.
- I'm gonna leave
right now. See you guys.
(audience laughter)
Alright, what about sports?
Your dad is a
hardcore Rams fan,
which I respect,
- Yeah.
- 'cause they're
not good either.
- No.
(audience laughter)
- Can you ever have it-
- [Man] What about the Jets?
- With the Jets, they're
gonna go 0 and 16 this year,
so just getting
mentally prepared.
Anything with you
and sports at this point?
Like, when the Lakers are good,
and you're a bandwagon fan?
- Um... you know...
So my husband grew
up with Baron Davis,
and so--
- Yep, I know that.
- We were fans of whatever
team he was on.
- Clips.
Knicks for a few minutes?
- Knicks for a little bit,
- Clippers.
- and then, Golden State.
If you know the
people who are playing,
then you feel more invested.
So whenever I go to a game,
and I'm like, "Hey, what's up?"
Like, that's fun.
(audience laughter)
But...
- But.
- I haven't gone
to games in a while.
- Okay.
- But they're very...
- Tall?
- Tall.
- Yep.
- And they're good at all the...
It's like special,
like you would never be
able to play basketball.
(audience laughter)
- Nope.
- For me, it's not
anything against you,
for me, but like...
- No, but listen,
somewhere around fourth grade,
was when I realized I was
more likely to own the Jets
then to play for them.
(audience laughter)
That's the punchline,
I'm not taking it.
Alright, let's
do some questions.
Who's got one?
- Oh wait, I have one
more thing with sports.
- Good, yeah, do your thing.
- So, we did a
collaboration with the MLB.
Do you like baseball?
- Oh yeah. I do, I've just
had my fantasy baseball draft,
Staats, are you here?
- Alright, stand up.
So, everybody boo Staats.
(audience laughter)
(audience booing)
He's my main
competitor this year
in fantasy baseball,
but he didn't draft very well,
so I'm feeling confident.
- So we did a
collaboration with MLB,
and we did diapers--
- I saw, I saw them
in your office.
- that have MLB logos, we had--
- Red Sox, Yanks--
six designs, and
they're super cute.
- Cardinals.
- Cubs?
- Knicks, Cubs --
- Knicks are basketball.
- Sorry, not Knicks.
(laughing)
- Mets.
- Not the Mets.
- Yankees, Dodgers,
and the Giants.
- San Francisco.
- Why do I keep
saying goddamn Jets?
- I love it.
(audience laughter)
Because you've been effected!
You've been effected!
- There's Jets everywhere!
- Alright, questions?
- [Hissan] Yes!
- Here, grab this.
And we have a mic over there and
we can go loud,
too, if we have to.
Go ahead.
- [Hissan] Hi.
- Say your name.
- [Hissan] I'm Hissan,
nice to meet you.
- [Jessica] Hi.
- So, Honest Baby went into
Target last week,
congratulations.
- Thank you!
(audience applause)
- [Hissan] With the brand moving
from specialty to mass retail,
what's your vision
for the next five years
in terms of growth?
- So, here's this weird thing,
because I don't
come from traditional
CPG or beauty background,
I don't I never understood that
the way that people
perceive your brand
or the integrity of
your brand or whatever
is based off of
distribution and not price point
or the quality
of your ingredients.
It literally, 100% has
to do with distribution.
But now that distribution has
all but flipped on its head,
with every D to C business
and with all of
these online retailers
who are taking people's lunch
and more people who are like,
"Give me an
excuse to leave my house
"and go into your door."
I just feel like this
is a transitional time,
and I, more than ever,
just want to make sure
that my products
are in peoples' hands,
and that my brand is
showcased in the best way.
So, I don't really have a bias
as to where I'm distributed.
I just want it to
have really great partners,
and I want it to
be done the right way.
- She has been
doing something super rad.
She's was doing Target Tuesdays?
- Target Tuesdays,
I'm going into
random Targets,
I'm finding random people,
and I'm giving them makeovers
on the spot on Facebook.
- So everybody, next Tuesday
you're allowed to be off,
pick a random Target,
and hold your breath.
(audience laughter)
- And so, today I did
two makeovers on Tuesdays.
- Did they lose their shit?
- I was like nervous.
What if they're
gonna not like it?
gonna say no to me?
- And sometimes they might
not know who you are, right?
I mean, there's like
four of those people.
- Yeah, of course,
yeah, absolutely!
And they might be like,
"Why are you touching my face?"
Like, I don't know!
- And?
- And they, and it went well.
- They loved it, yeah.
(audience laughter)
- Thank God!
- Alright, who
else has got a question?
Dante!
Get up here, baby!
That was awesome.
Dante, that was,
yeah, you brought it.
- [Dante] So, we're going to
be influencer department, here
and I'm sure that, you know,
we've seen posts from
big, influential individuals,
people with many followers.
How do you think that
has contributed to the growth
of your business on social,
just having those type of people
speaking about your brand.
- I think...
Influencers are tricky.
I actually feel like
the influencers that have
the most followers
maybe aren't as trusted
as people who
have a few thousand
or in the high hundreds.
Because, to me,
it's like the people who
have that authentic engagement
and have that
rabid fan base is more
the people that are
going to affect change
versus someone who's
just so giant because--
- Because they're
pitching products every day,
is your thought?
- Or because they're
just part of a machine,
and most of the people that
are following them are bots.
We know that that
whole thing can be gamed.
I was never one of those people.
I never bought
any of my followers,
and I do everything myself,
and there's no agency
or other people that
do, you know--
- Your engagement.
- My engagement,
but also it was like,
for me to be honest,
why I'm so involved
in my online persona is
because I felt like my entire
career I was in
someone else's hands.
So, whether it was Fox's hands--
- The Hollywood Machine.
- Or the machine of the
production company Paramount,
or Sony, or whoever, and how
they wanted to market me,
or the publication that wanted
to do the interview of me.
I was this version
for the GQ reader,
and I was that version for
the Seventeen Magazine reader,
the People Magazine reader.
No part of it was really me.
- It was pieces.
- For the first time,
I really got to tell
my story, and I got to be real
and I got to have
that direct relationship
with myself and have
control over who I am.
- The exact quote, the
exact way, to the end user.
- Yeah, and I never
got to do that before,
and so, that's why
I care about it so much,
and that's why
I've been so involved.
- And yeah, Rahm.
- [Rahm] I think that,
kind of an interesting segway
into what I'm curious
about, which is,
obviously you
have invested so much
of your personal brand
into The Honest Company.
You're like, proud of
that and you feel like
that's kind of your
most authentic self.
Does it frustrate you if people
would still say, oh yeah,
like if tonight
someone went home
and said I saw
Jessica Alba, the actress?
Or would you feel like
that's just part
of your broader story?
- Before you answer that,
I just want to make sure
the other offices
that that are watching.
So the question is,
Rahm is asking is,
if somebody went
home tonight and said,
"Oh I saw
Jessica Alba, the actress."
You put so much time and effort
in building this business
and yourself into it.
I guess the question is,
would she be frustrated
being identified as that?
- I guess it depends on the--
- In the beginning
probably more, right?
- No, it really
depends on the context.
I mean, if people know me more
from one thing versus another,
I can't expect them
to not know me for that,
and I'm grateful that I
was given the opportunity
to have the
career in entertainment
that I got to have.
I actually miss
acting. (laughs)
It's so weird.
- We need some people
for some of our videos, so...
- I'll do it.
- Great.
Booked.
(audience laughter)
- My husband's
always like, really?
No I actually do, I miss it.
- Do you think that
means you'll probably do it?
- You know, I don't know--
- Do you think about
71 year old you, acting?
- Here's the thing when you're
acting, you can always do it
and you only stop
doing it when you are like,
alright I never want
to play that role--
- Right, it's not
like an NBA player right?
Like you've got that window.
- No you don't have
an expiration date.
Now will you always
get paid the same money
or will you still be the ingeneu
for the rest of your life?
No, but do you get to
evolve into different,
more meatier
different types of people?
Sure.
- Are you going to
be like a funny grandma?
- Yeah.
I'm going to be
the funniest grandma.
(Gary laughs)
Are you kidding?
So I miss it, I do.
Do I care if people
think of me as an actress?
It depends on the context.
If someone is just
trying to be mean spirited
and take away what
I've built, then sure.
It hurts my feelings.
I am a sensitive person.
But if someone just
doesn't really know me
from anything else, then
I'm like alright, that's cool.
- Good.
Anybody else?
Yep, great, hey Elise.
- [Elise] Hi. What brings
you the most joy?
Would you say it's your acting
or would you say it's
your business venture,
or something else?
- I probably have like
an unhealthy relationship
with acting.
It's like the boyfriend who's
never really that into you.
(audience laughter)
- Tell me more.
- Exactly like Gary.
(audience laughter)
Just want him to not look
over my shoulder in (mumbles)
this time, but he's always
interested in what's going on.
- It's true.
Where's the camera?
- Yeah, I have to say
though, as far as legacy,
in all seriousness,
and personal fulfillment,
I've never, I've never even,
I've never thought
that I would be able to
have such a full life.
And being an entrepreneur
and being able to
create a company
and create a vision
and create solutions for people
that'll really
transform their lives.
And also to watch people
really grow up
in their own lives,
in their own careers.
And watch personal development
on such an intimate level.
'Cause prior to this,
I would spend a lot of time,
with strangers,
for about four months,
and then I'd
never see them again.
But the time that I spent
with them was every day,
all day and night.
- And it was the best.
And you create those,
some really intimate
relationships quickly,
but then they go away
and it was so fleeting.
But there's
something so permanent
about going into
the office everyday
and I see the same
people that I saw five years ago
and I see who they are today
versus who they were when
they walked in five years ago
and that's so dope,
just to see how people evolve
and to have those
personal connections.
- Love that.
Yep?
Rebec, you can
come up to the mic.
Oh, you've got one? Go ahead.
Go ahead, go ahead,
go ahead, go ahead.
- [Man] You've done a
lot of really cool work,
specifically with kids,
what's the most powerful
experience that
you've had helping kids,
and how has that
impacted the other choices
that you make in your life?
- Wow.
- [Man] Curveball.
- Yeah, I know, this
is a loaded question,
because I feel like
I'm 100 percent
have dedicated my life
in a weird way to helping kids,
and this is the
first time that I actually
kind of thought
about it that way, but--
- Dude.
(audience laughter)
- This is huge.
(audience laughing and applause)
- I was a really sick
kid when I was younger,
and I wanted to,
literally anything
would be better
than to be sick and
to be in the hospital
and to have surgery, and
I had multiple surgeries,
and multiple health problems.
And I just, I literally just
wanted to be anyone else,
which was why
I wanted to be an actor.
Because it was like a way
for that to actually be real,
as real as it can be,
and certainly be a superhero,
and be larger than life.
'Cause I was like, they
can overcome anything!
And so, yeah, from helping,
being able to
provide families with
products is one thing,
but even just basic essentials.
Infant mortality is a
huge issue in this country,
and a lot of babies get
suffocated while
they're sleeping,
because parents
can't provide a safe place
for them to sleep,
and we did an initiative
where we provided, and we
still have an ongoing thing
among the board of this
organization called Baby2Baby,
and one of our big
initiatives is to give families
a safe place for
their new baby to sleep,
so that they never
have to worry about that.
That's a real thing,
and that's
incredibly meaningful.
I also got the opportunity
to go to Africa with Bono,
and Queen Rania
around the World Cup,
to fight for education reform,
a global education fund
so that every
person had access
to a comprehensive
education, and most people who
don't have access are women.
So that is
incredibly meaningful,
and being able to give
girls an opportunity to
just empower themselves to
get themselves
out of the situation
that they don't
want to be in, and change
their family's
life and their own life.
There's been a lot
of these circumstances.
Yeah, just thinking
about it, it's very cool
because I don't
often get to, but probably
raising my own little
stinkers has probably been
the most meaningful,
but being able to
be part of so much change,
and as scary and weird
and crazy as our
country feels right now,
with certain political things,
I feel like there's
enough of us out there
that walk with integrity
and care about the right things,
and we're going to
continue to be progressive
in how we operate,
and that we'll always win.
- Awesome.
(audience applause)
- I think the thing
that I have learned
that no one told me, it's
sort of like being a parent.
No one tells you
what you're really in for
as far as the sleepless nights,
and you'll never not
worry again thing that happens.
In business, you never
underestimate your gut.
There's a lot that
you can learn in school
and through experience,
and making mistakes,
but trusting your gut and
knowing what you don't know
is just as important as
knowing what you do know.
And being able to have
the humility to support
what you don't know
with experts and other people
to fill those gaps,
and trusting your gut.
- Love it.
Go ahead.
Here, grab this, yeah.
- [Tatiana] I don't need a mic.
- Go ahead, but they need it.
- [Tatiana] Thank you.
Hi, my name is Tatiana.
I'm Peruvian-American,
I'm Latina, so
my question is going
to be related to that.
I think today, it's
exciting to see representation
of our mission both
onscreen and off where
there wasn't always.
- Yeah.
- [Tatiana] That being said,
it hasn't always
been easy and I think,
especially with
today's political climate,
what I would love to know is
what advice do you have for
young Latina entrepreneurs
that are looking to build
businesses and be successful?
If you faced any
specific challenges
or advantages in that respect?
- Advantages, no.
(audience laughter)
You'd have to be a
white guy if
you want advantages.
(audience chuckles)
I mean, that's
just the way it is.
It helps if you're
tall and good-looking, too.
You know, being a girl who's
just trying to figure it out
and doesn't, you know, for me,
I'm just talking
from my experience,
I never had a traditiona
lor conventional background
or education, nor did
I have nepotism that got me
to where I'm at,
and I literally
had to pay my own way,
and I had to figure it out
and create that path and
have the vision for myself.
It was almost the
naysayers that drove me
to prove them wrong.
And also, when you don't
have anywhere to go but up,
there's almost
something nice about that
because people
don't expect you to fail
because they don't
think you're capable
of doing anything
more than nothing.
And so, then,
there's even more of a fire
to prove to them that you can.
And that you can
make a difference.
What can you do?
I think you have to
first, really
figure out what it is
you're trying
to do in the world.
How are you
going to be different?
Look at a competitive landscape
be very realistic with yourself.
And make sure that you
have a very unique proposition
or perspective or point of view
because if you're
just a "me, too" company...
Why?
Why do it?
- I think the one
thing that I would add just
I'll jump into this one
'cause I love it so much.
I think the one thing
that true entrepreneurs need
to realize is that
the market doesn't care.
Let me tell you one
great thing about the market,
it wants to make money.
Do I think some VCs may say,
"You don't look the part, no"?
Sure, but I've got a news alert.
I don't usually invest
in white, affluent dudes
from good families because
I don't think they have a chip
on their shoulder.
So, I'm playing the reverse.
And the truth is, I've been
wrong, and I've been right.
So, I think the one great
if you're a
pure-bred entrepreneur,
you realize you're getting
punched in the fucking mouth
24/7, 365 anyway.
The market is the market,
and if you dwell
on what you are,
and why you're not
winning because of that,
you would have never had a,
it's no different than
the people we said no to.
- You can't, sorry--
- Please.
- You can't be a
victim of circumstance.
It's sort of like
blaming your parents
it's like yeah, right.
Everyone has a history
and you can blame your parents
until you're blue in the face,
but if you only
work on, focus on that,
you'll never get
over it and be an adult,
and figure your own life out.
And, by the way,
your parents are just
trying the best they could,
and there's no manual,
which I learned later in life.
(audience laughter)
I think if I would've
started The Honest Company
when I wanted to start,
it would've been too early.
And actually having
three years of rejection
it gave me the
armor to take on
actually getting funding
and starting the company,
and taking all of
the punches in my face
and my eyes and
my ear and my nose
that constantly came at me.
- And still do, everyday.
- And still do,
everyday, of course.
But I have more calluses
and so I can take it
differently than I could have.
- We'll sneak in
two quick ones, sorry Jess. Pam.
- [Pam] Hey, I'm Pamela, and
thank you again for being here.
My question is a little
bit more about the blend
of your personal life
and your professional life
and what a typical
day looks like for you
if there is a typical day.
And then, if you have any
rules of thumb or tips
and ways that you keep
your friendships alive,
your relationship and
your family time protected,
and also the type of
passion projects in your job.
- Does it look like I
have it all figured out?
(audience laughter)
'Cause I really don't.
I'm always everyday just
trying to do the best I can.
No two days are the same.
I'm constantly
trying to create routines
'cause I feel likes
that's good, and everything
that I've read
about successful people is
that they start early.
I hate waking up early.
It hurts all of my feelings.
Every time I wake up early
it's just like why me.
(audience laughter)
But I've read so much
that successful people.
I feel like you start early.
- It's not early or late.
For me it's just
maximizing when I'm awake.
People are always
like how much do you sleep?
Thinking I'm
gonna say three or four.
I'm dying to get six or seven
'cause I think it's healthy.
- Yeah you need it. you need it.
- It's just that I'm
fucking on all 18 hours
when I'm awake, right?
- Yeah, he is.
(audience laughter)
- Oh, they know.
(Jessica laughs)
- I wish I figured
out the secret sauce.
I don't know.
I have friends that
I was really close with
at certain periods of time,
and now we're not,
and now I have other friends
that I'm really close with.
I kind of give myself a break.
(audience laughter)
I just think that if you can
not think of the pressure
of society and
who you need to be,
and you're just really true
with who you are and know
that you're trying
to do the best you can,
you can kind of
just figure it out.
That's my theory.
It's probably wrong,
but I wish I was better
at waking up early, and
eating healthy, and exercising,
and calling my mom.
I'm just not good at stuff,
but I'm good at
being with my kids
and telling them about things,
and when they yell at me
enough about the same
thing over and over again,
I can sometimes
say okay, you're right.
I'm probably
doing the wrong thing,
and I'll try to
do better next time.
- [Jermaine] Hi,
my name is Jermaine.
My question is more
on entrepreneurship.
What are your top three
factors that inspired you
to become an entrepreneur?
And what order would you
rank those three factors?
- Three factors that inspired
me to be an entrepreneur.
Social justice was my big one.
I felt like it was completely
unfair that only people
who lived in a
certain tax bracket
deserved to have a
better life and had access
to not just better products,
but more education
to make better choices.
I would say that's
one, two, and three.
I went and lobbied
for chemical reform
and tried to work at that angle,
and I got nowhere.
They made it a partisan issue,
and it's a human health issue.
When you're like
this is a civil right.
People should just
know what's in stuff
and how it's going
to effect their health,
and the fact that the
government won't protect us,
someone needs to
go out there and prove
that people want this,
and people will vote
with their wallets.
That's what really
drove me everyday,
and that's what still drives me.
- Jess, thank you so
much for stopping by.
- Yeah, thank you.
- I love you.
(audience applause)